As you may have heard by now, my new
book, The Two Swords of Christ, about
the Knights of the Temple and Hospital
and their savage wars against Islam, is
less than three weeks away from being
released. Now, by way of preparation, I
wanted to briefly discuss the logic and
rationale, and most importantly, the
theology that gave rise to these two
brotherhoods. So, let's take a look at
the seinal documents of the Templars,
history's first Christian military
order, titled In Praise of the Newhood.
It was written by St. Bernard of Clervo
shortly after the formal recognition of
the Knights Templars in 1129 AD. It
begins by showing that the Templars do
indeed represent a new but also much
needed creature, the fusion of monk and
warrior, so that the two realms of
Christian warfare that had hitherto been
separated, the incorporeal and corporeal
or spiritual and secular could be
confronted by the self-same warrior
monk. In the words of Bernard, this is a
new kind of knighthood and one unknown
in ages past. It ceaselessly wages a
two-fold combat against flesh and blood
and against spiritual hosts of evil in
the heavens. That latter part, of
course, is a reference to Ephesians
6:12. Nothing, Bernard continues, is new
or shocking about warriors who fight
their foes with might and man, or of
monks who combat demons through fasting
and prayer. But for a man to powerfully
guard himself with both swords,
spiritual and secular, and mark his belt
with the cross, who would not consider
this worthy of great admiration, even
more so since it has hitherto been
unknown? Truly a fearless knight and
secure on every side is he whose soul is
protected by the armor of faith, just as
his body is protected by armor of steel.
Doubly armed, surely he need fear
neither demons nor men. Not that he
fears death. No, he desires it. Why
should he fear to live or to die when
for him to live is Christ and to die is
gain? March forth confidently then
unites and with a stalwart heart repel
the foes of the cross of Christ. Be sure
that neither death nor life can separate
you from the love of God which is in
Jesus Christ. As shocking as Bernard's
words may be to modern-day Christians,
they are also logically consistent.
Consider, if it is acceptable to fend
off Satan's fiery darts against the
soul, why is it not acceptable to fight
off the enemies of Christianity who
terrorize Christians not just with fiery
darts, but with swords, spears, and
cruelty unbounded? Indeed, although
forgotten today, both swords mentioned
by Bernard are a reference to Luke
22:38, where Christ told his disciples
that two swords are enough. For preodern
theologians, this was Christ's way of
legitimizing two forms of warfare. One
with a spiritual sword against spiritual
enemies and one with a physical sword
against physical enemies, also known as
just war. Thus, nearly a century after
Bernard James of Vitri, the bishop of
Aker, preached of how sariss and pagans
undermine the peace of Christendom,
tyrants and evil Christians attack the
liberty of the church, and false
brothers undermine love. Against the
violence of the pagans and sariss, it
the church uses the physical sword,
hence the crusades. Against tyrants and
false brothers, it uses a spiritual
sword. Since the church has two swords,
which the Lord said is enough, one is to
be exercised in a spiritual sense by the
prelates, the other by the princes and
military Christians. James of vitri went
so far as to assert that quote only
heretics argue that it is not Christian
to fight and cite scripture to prove
this. They lying assert that it is not
permissible for you to take up a
physical sword nor to fight bodily
against the enemies of the church. They
abuse the authority of the scriptures
and present petty reasons. And if we did
not resist the church's enemies, the
sariss and heretics would have already
devastated the whole church. In fact,
knighthood was set up in order to repel
violence, repulse injuries, and exercise
justice on evildoers. Not much has
changed, eh? I can just see and hear all
the doormat Christians ringing their
hands and whining about how uncchristian
it is to repel violence, repulse
injuries, and exercise justice on
evildoers. To quote James of Vitri.
Anyway, returning to Bernard of Clervau,
this important spokesman for all
military orders went on to argue as St.
Augustine did before him that fighting,
even killing are not intrinsically evil.
Rather, it's the intention and
motivation of the fighter that decides
the matter. Bernard continues, "Indeed,
a danger or victory for the Christian
are weighed by the focus of the heart,
not the fortunes of war. If he fights
for a good cause, the outcome of the
battle can never be evil. And likewise,
the result can never be considered good
if the cause is evil and the intention
unrighteous." There go the overwhelming
majority of modern-day wars, the
intentions of which, if you only really
knew, are seldom righteous. The New
Knights, Bernard said, were engaged in
malicide, not homicide. Their purpose
was to exterminate evil, not evildoers,
who in this context were seen as
collateral damage. In the saint's own
words,
>> surely if he kills an evildoer, he is
not a man killer, but if I may so put
it, an evil killer.
>> Bernard goes on to compare and contrast
the new knighthood with the secular and
by then quite ostentatious knighthood.
Not only do the latter fight and kill
for vain uncchristian reasons, for fame,
gain, vengeance, or from wrath, but they
dress effeminately, said he, and
ornament themselves and their horses
with bobbles befitting the trinkets of a
woman, his words. In stark contrast, the
Templars and other military orders had a
decidedly manly look and austere
outlook. Along with going against
Frankish custom by refusing to shave and
letting their beards grow long,
apparently in keeping with God's design
and therefore will, they quote cut their
hair short, cognizant that according to
the apostle, it is shameful for a man to
cultivate flowing locks. Bernard is here
referring to 1 Corinthians 11:14-16.
He continues, "When battle is imminent,
they the Templars protect themselves
inwardly by their faith and outwardly by
iron, not gold, so that armed and not
adorned, they strike fear into the enemy
rather than arousing his greed, to
plunder them of their trinkets. They
seek to have strong and swift horses,
not ones decked out in many colors. They
are intent on fighting, not pomp,
victory, not glory. And they strive to
inspire terror, not admiration. Worse,
because the secular knighthood fight and
kill for, in Bernard's words, slight and
frivolous reasons, including irrational
anger, empty glory, and earthly
possessions, it is for them not safe to
kill or be killed, as hell would be a
possible consequence. In contrast, the
knights of Christ may safely do battle
in the battles of their Lord, fearing
neither the sin of smiting the enemy nor
the danger of their own downfall. In as
much as death for Christ inflicted or
endured, bears no taint of sin, but
deserves abundant glory. For the record,
the idea that Christians who die
fighting for the faith are martyrs far
predates Bernard and even the first
crusade in 1095. It actually goes back
to at least the mid 800s under popes Leo
IV and John VII and was widely accepted
by most Western European theologians. In
the words of William of Tier, the 12th
century chronicler, "We believe indeed
that those who fall in the ranks of the
faithful fighting with the warriors of
the cross for the name of Christ deserve
that not only disgrace but all
derelictions whatsoever be erased from
their records." None of this, of course,
was seen as a license to kill. Bernard
insisted that Muslims should not quote
be slaughtered when there is any other
way of preventing them from harassing
and persecuting the faithful end quote.
However, because Muslims had for
centuries proven themselves existential
intractable enemies to Christians, it
now seems better to destroy them than to
allow the rod of sinners to continue to
be raised over the lot of the righteous,
lest per chance the righteous set their
hand to iniquity. He was referring to
the then well-known fact that to escape
persecution, lots of Christians had
converted over the centuries. If, as
Bernard continues to argue, Christians
are not forbidden from fighting,
provided it's for a just cause, then
they must certainly stand up to Muslims
who from the start had waged and
continued to wage a wholly unjust war on
Christendom. No room for cheek turning
here. Surely then, the nations who
choose warfare should be scattered.
Those who molest us should be cut away,
and all the workers of iniquity should
be dispersed from the city of the Lord.
Those who busy themselves carrying off
the incalculable riches placed in
Jerusalem by Christian people profaining
holy things and possessing the sanctuary
of God as their heritage. He's referring
to the Muslims. Let both swords of the
faithful fall upon the necks of the foe
who represented both secular and
spiritual evil.
Let both swords fall on the neck of the
foe to the destruction of every lofty
thing, lifting itself up against the
knowledge of God, which is the Christian
faith. Lest the Gentiles should then
say, "Where is their God?" For Bernard,
even the Templar's headquarters,
Solomon's temple, or Al Axa Mosque,
underscored the muscular, nononsense
side of Christianity. For was it not at
the temple that Christ himself engaged
in righteous violence? Argued the same.
The facade of this temple is now adorned
with weapons rather than jewels. And in
place of the ancient golden crowns, its
walls are hung round with shields. In
place of candlesticks, sensors and eers,
this house is well furnished with
saddles, bridles, and lances. By all
these signs the knights clearly show
that they are animated by the same zeal
for the house of God which of old
vehemently inflamed the leader of
knighthood himself Christ who having his
most sacred hands armed not with a
weapon but with a whip which he had
fashioned from lengths of cord entered
the temple ousted the merchants
scattered the coins of the money
changers and overturned the chairs of
the pigeon vendors considering it
totally unfitting to defile this house
of prayer by such traffic. moved
therefore by their king's example is
devoted soldierly, the Templars,
considering it far more unfitting and
infinitely more intolerable for a holy
place to be polluted by unbelievers than
to be crowded with merchants, have
installed themselves in this holy house
with their horses and their armor.
Having expuned it and the other holy
places of every infidel stain and the
tyrannical horde, they occupy themselves
day and night with work as distinguished
as it is practical. They honor the
temple of God earnestly with fervent and
sincere worship in their devotion,
offering up not the flesh of animals,
according to the ancient writes, but
true peace offerings, brotherly love,
devoted obedience, and voluntary
poverty. For Bernard, the lifestyle of
the knights of the temple, both in peace
and war, is quote, "an exemplar, or at
least an embarrassment for those of our
knights who are apparently fighting not
for God, but for the devil end quote."
Abiding in perfect discipline and
obedience, the Templars, Bernard
continues, live in cheerful community
and sober company, without wives and
without children, so that their
evangelical perfection will lack
nothing. They dwell united in one family
with no personal property whenever,
careful to keep the unity of the spirit
in the bond of peace. They never sit in
idleness or wander about aimlessly, but
on the rare occasions when they are not
on duty, they are always careful to earn
their bread. There is little distinction
of persons among them and difference is
shown to ability, not to nobility. They
rival one another in mutual
consideration, and they carry one
another's burdens, thus fulfilling the
law of Christ. No arrogant word, no idol
deed, no unrestrained laugh, not even
the slightest whisper or murmur is left
uncorrected. That said, once the call to
battle is heard, these seeming saints
turned into raging devils. Or in the
more restrained words of Bernard, once
in the thick of battle, they set aside
this earlier gentleness as if to say,
"Do I not hate those who hate you, oh
Lord? Am I not disgusted with your
enemies?" This is a reference to Psalm
138:21. These men charge the enemy
regarding the foe as sheep. Never, no
matter how outnumbered they are, do they
see them as awesome hordes, nor do they
presume on their own strength, but trust
for victory in the Lord. For one man may
pursue a thousand, and two put 10,000 to
flight. This is a reference to
Deuteronomy 32:30. This then was the
riddle of the Templars. They appear
gentler than lambs, yet fiercer than
lions. Consequently, I do not know if it
would be more appropriate to refer to
them as monks or as soldiers, or whether
it would perhaps be better to recognize
them as being both, for they lack
neither monastic meekness nor military
might. What can we say about this except
that this is the Lord's doing, and it is
marvelous in our eyes. Okay, there it
is. of the logic and theology that gave
rise to the Templars, history's first
Christian military order. For the full
story of the Templars, consider
pre-ordering The Two Swords of Christ.
Or to get an advanced signed copy, see
the link in the description.